but I do not believe that what happened
in East Palestine is the fault of
deregulation or Donald Trump it's the
fault of well there's a lot of reasons
that there's a lot of problems with this
one the rail workers have been
complaining about the private companies
and and the safety issues whether or not
they deregulate some of these things is
not an excuse for a company to do things
poorly not to mention you were talking
about this before the show the
infrastructure bill so when they were
coming out and saying that what were
they saying that like social justice was
infrastructure everything was
infrastructure Child Care was
infrastructure that was a big one
um anything that they wanted Federal
funding for became infrastructure I
believe they said abortion was
infrastructure
um uh yeah the child care is a big one
so they were really going at any sort of
women's rights that was all that means
rights or infrastructure everything was
infrastructure except infrastructure the
railroads how